and Las Vegas Bowl all happening here in
town tomorrow now remember when the
Raiders and Patriots worked out and
scrimmaged here in Vegas in the
preseason that was back in August you
can see the Patriots way in the
background there out in Henderson
but okay they meet for real for real uh
on Sunday
in fact the Patriots actually have been
in town somewhere in town since they
played in Arizona on Sunday Bill
Belichick hasn't returned my calls to
find out exactly where they were in town
but okay okay that happens I also want
to mention this is sort of important 100
Renfro and Darren Waller are back at
workouts at least they're back at
workouts both guys have been out for
much of the season with injuries still
no word if they will play on Sunday so
that's the other question this was video
taken a while back because you see them
in shorts so Ryan you need a larger
Noggin buddy does this hat make me look
small
that doesn't make them look small this
is the one thing they gave these out
after the one Vegas event tonight at the
legion setting for the bowl game for the
Southern Nevada Sports Hall of Fame big
charity event tonight so these I said I
had to wear this hat tonight but it does
make me people are adjusting their
television it helps no it helps
concussion protocol too in The Newsroom
you never know when you're gonna get
knocked over I wonder if they over did
the Pinot Noir we'll be back in a few
minutes it's really that